a couple of details at the market so
let's just talk about a new law that is
hit on it's affecting some of your
retirement opportunities and some of the
things that are out there okay it's
called the secure act and it's a piece
of legislation that happened last year
and it's taking effect here at the
beginning of 2020 stands for setting
every community up for retirement secure
change in the federal law about your
retirement and there are basically six
five or six seven changes that you need
to think about and know about in the tax
law and we'll talk about them from time
to time as a caller calls in and these
will be new answers to old questions
because the law has changed one of the
things that changed a few years ago is
you can name a beneficiary to your IRA
and so if your parents pass away they
could leave you a hundred thousand
dollars in an IRA it's called an
inherited IRA and the way it used to be
was is there's no penalties for taking
the money out but you do pay the taxes
at your tax rate when you take the money
out of the inherited IRA if you choose
not to take any money out there was a
required minimum distribution in RMD you
had to take a tiny bit out every year
that law has changed they are now
forcing you to take all of the rare
inherited IRA within ten years and so if
you get a hundred thousand dollars
you're going to pull ten thousand a year
minimum they want their tax money on it
so they're forcing you to take the
inherited IRA quicker then you might
have wanted to now you might have wanted
to take it out anyway and pay off the
debt I don't tell you to take out other
retirement early and pay off debt but
this has no penalty on it only taxes and
so I typically tell you to cash-in
tonight inherited IRA if you're trying
to hit some of your other financial
goals anyway but if you were not wanting
to do that
well Tuffy's now you got to pull it out
in ten years over the ten-year period of
time good news is a traditional IRA if
you had money in that you were forced to
begin
distributions at 70 and a half whether
you wanted to or not again the RMD the
required minimum distributions you had
to start taking that the law has changed
in your favor now it is 72 not 70 and a
half so you get another year and a half
to leave your money alone if you want to
those of you approaching retirement that
have a traditional IRA and another thing
that changed about it was we're not
allowed to put money into a traditional
IRA after 70 and a half and now you are
as long as you're making an earned
income you can bet take out a
traditional IRA but again when you're
over 70 - there's a required minimum
distribution over 72 it used to be 70
and a half and you might see a new
annuity option in your 401k don't do it
but there's going to be you're going to
see a lot more annuities popping up
through the secured act and you can turn
a lump sum of money into a guaranteed
income for life it's not a good idea
don't do it but you're gonna start
seeing the annuities popping up inside
of the 401ks because of this act secure
act also gives you more access to your
401k for part-time or small-business
workers it's easy for small businesses
to work together to offer 401k plan to
their collective employees helping out
with the cost I wouldn't fool with that
either there were pretty easy ways to do
it that we're inexpensive anyway the
simple IRA is basically a 401k for small
businesses you can do that there's not
that much cost to that anyway you can do
SEPs if you have almost no employees
there's no cost to that anyway hardly
other than the Commission's when you're
buying the mutual funds that's it
parents can withdraw $5,000 from
retirement penalty free upon the birth
or adoption of a child that's stupid
don't do that pay for the adoption or
birth of your children don't cash in
your retirement for doing that even if
you can legally you can take your money
on your Roth IRA to buy a house to
don't do it okay and the last thing they
changed in the law was parents may
withdraw up to $10,000 from 529 plans to
repay student loans for their child
now that's awesome but it begs the
question if you have $10,000 in your 529
why the flip is there a student loan why
didn't you just pay for the tuition but
if you've got 529s
you know and somehow by hook or crook
you ended up with one kid that had loans
and one that didn't one's got money in a
529 one doesn't you can always do stuff
for siblings anyway already with 529s
but if somehow by some weird
circumstance you end up with a student
loan debt while you have a 529 balance
with your kid you can use that money to
pay the kids student loans so you can
withdraw up to $10,000 from 529 plans to
repay student loans if you have money
left over now that could be you could be
in a 529 plan in your name but you're
allowed to use that for tuition anyway
you can use a 529 plan for any relative
it used to be siblings only and that was
all where that laws already changed so
if you had a 529 plan mama and you
didn't use it all you can use it to send
your baby to college and if you didn't
and you took out a student loan anyway
well that's stupid so go ahead and take
the 529 aisle and pay off the student
loan it's now perfectly legal to do that
and not cause any problems you couldn't
you know you couldn't ever use it to pay
student loans before that's new but I
don't know why you would you wouldn't
have a student loan if you had a 529
you'd use the money to go to school so
it's just silly but anyway a couple of
these laws changes are awesome and are
gonna work in your favor you can
especially this thing where you can
leave your 401k alone now until 72
instead of 70 and a half and you can no
matter how old you are you can open a
traditional for Oh Aisha my array as
long as you have an earned income and
that allows you to do that at any age
but you will have to begin know if
you're over 70
you'll have 272 you'll immediately have
to begin required minimum distributions
the rest of these changes really are not
you know they give you some flexibility
but most of them are dumb ideas
annuities in your 401k dumb idea you
know sharing a 401k plan with other
small businesses and a collective
generally a dumb idea
taking $5,000 out because you had a baby
out of your retirement dumb idea taking
money out of a 529 to pay off a student
loan when you should have just used the
529 loan 529 money to pay the tuition in
the first place I guess that's a smart
idea now but I understand why it's there
so doesn't make any sense and of course
that inherited IRAs are taking your
money making you pay the taxes on the
money sooner and pulling it out of there
bad for you so really only one of these
seven provisions is actually great for
you the rest of them allow you to do
stupid things so be careful this is your
government here to help